this shot is incredible like the
shipwreck sanctum
it's like i think all the snow melted i
don't even know what the hell is going
on there yeah yeah
and then time door maybe
all of this
welcome back to new rock stars doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness is
currently the next mcu title in 2022 it
just officially wrapped production in
the past week and now the scoopers are
running wild with rumors that this film
will be a celebration of marvel's full
history including insane cameos that we
could never conceive of so will this be
the mcu title that finally finally
introduces the mutants to the mcu or
will the scarlet witch kill off some of
our beloved x-men
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
i just i it was it's been a year since
wanda vision i wanted to go back to one
of the [ __ ]
i love it this is inside marvel it's our
weekly marvel reaction show talking
about the latest and greatest in the
marvel cinematic universe i'm eric voss
i'm back this week with mt hey mt how
you doing this week hey man i'm just
thinking only and only about multi
worship madness because this evil doctor
strange like i don't know what's going
on there and like i don't even know
what's going on with all this fox mutant
x-men talk what's going on there we're
hearing a lot we're hearing a lot of
news out there most of it's unconfirmed
of course right it's no way home all
over again uh but that's kind of the fun
of this as we look ahead because now
unlike last year when we had a no way
home trailer we had like other stuff
like what if we had hawkeye we had
eternals we had shangshi to kind of
distract us and keep us fed now right
now we are back in the middle of the
desert when it comes to marvel content
between now unless we get moon night
hopefully moon night will drop sometime
speaking of being in the middle of the
desert mood night
yeah as of this taping we don't know
when moon knight will drop
this episode we're going to break down
the rumors that we've heard about
multiverse madness and after that wild
year of 2021 we want to reassess what
seems to be kevin feige's mutant plan
because he must have a plan for how he's
going to introduce some mutants and yeah
we've talked about a lot but i just want
to look at like where the state of
things are now after some of these
titles and see if we've gotten some
information about
what that plan might be but before we
get to that new rockstars has a fun
announcement we want to make if any of
our folks that follow our channel live
in the chicagoland area we are actually
doing a special live event you can see
me and jessica clements tommy bechtel
phil molina live in person on february
11th we're gonna do a live new rockstar
show with our wonderful friends at
rooster teeth and the face jam podcast
at thalia hall in chicago as part of the
very normal podcast tour with a crew
like this you know it's gonna be a real
fun silly time uh we'll be announcing
more information about it as as we get
closer it's it's a few weeks away we're
still waiting to learn a few more pieces
of information before we can announce it
to you guys uh but as of right now we're
very much looking forward to it you can
check the link in the video's
description uh or new rockstar social
media accounts for that ticket info all
right but mt what is this question that
we're going to talk about today on
instagram eric wanda the f will
multiverse of madness introduce mutants
to the mcu because that's got to be
coming because we got wanda and the
multiverse and we got the x-men in the
multiverse so oh what is that gonna
happen what's the plan there yes what is
that plan we've asked this question a
lot at new rockstars if you've watched
any of our videos it's just it's a
natural conversation point we always
come back to but now that we are on the
other side of that sprint last year that
started with one division and then went
right into falcon winter soldier then we
had a couple trailers for stuff coming
out then we had loki then we had black
widow in the middle of loki then we had
what if and then in the middle of what
if we got some no way home trailer
content and then we got shang chi and
then we had eternal life and hawkeye and
then no way home's release it was a
crazy jam-packed year uh and now based
off of all that we have a lot more
information about what marvel's overall
game plan seems to be for things like
the mutants it's been about a year later
because one year ago in january 2021 we
were just starting to see what one
division was gonna be and it seemed like
marvel at that point had two paths ahead
for how to introduce the mutants one
path would be the multiverse crossover
path the other one would be this uh what
i thought would be simpler already their
path uh multiverse crossover of course
would mean bringing back the actors who
played these characters in other
franchises already there would be this
kind of thing like oh
wolverine has been in this universe the
whole time we just haven't met him yet
he's just been running around the woods
of canada and uh and now this is the
actors playing him but he just kind of
stayed out of the fights or was fighting
the infinity war fight on a different
front that we didn't see canada was so
far away we didn't hear about the
mutants
right yeah or like storm was right there
behind giant man in the endgame final
battle we just didn't see her yeah it
seems like a stretch but like you know
it wouldn't be that hard just to tilt
the camera and revisiting this footage
and say oh it was right there but um
this would probably mean to recast like
the fox x-men the you know these other
characters that we know um now titles
like one division and loki and what if
seem to be the kind of shows that might
suggest a use of a multiverse crossover
to bring mutants from one universe into
this one in fact it seemed like we were
getting that for a hot second with evan
peters and wanavision but no
it was just ralph boner
just a boner we all should have just
assumed it was ralph boner honestly i
mean what were we thinking we should
what were we thinking getting all
excited about that well i don't think
our excitement was stupid mt i actually
think that was the first step in a plan
and after may 2022 we're gonna look back
at that and realize no no
this was part of the plan they knew what
they were doing and they're going to fix
it in multiples of madness they have to
well meanwhile when we got titles like
the falcon the winter soldier black
widow shungi eternals hawkeye all these
earth-based stories for the most part
these seem like stories that might hint
mutants could have already been hiding
on earth already but also no you know we
did get a bit of an ursa major
cameo in black widow but i don't know if
that really counts because it's just the
actor who played uh
the big russian bear in the seventh
circle prison sane he was ursa major uh
unless it comes out of feige's mouth i i
don't think we can count it yet but now
we're on the other side of spider-man no
way home and the next title released by
marvel is going to be multiverse of
madness i think marvel is showing its
cards to us they're going to use the
multiverse to do this now there's no way
marvel is going to follow no way home
with a movie with multiverse in the
title and not aim to top it with even
more insane cameos in this multiverse of
madness trailer i think gives us a huge
clue to this crossover with the marvel
studios title card which for the first
time flickers back to past eras of
marvel studios fanfare including the
versions of the marvel logos that were
used in front of other franchise films
like sony and like the fox marvel films
i think that's deliberate i think it is
happening i think we're finally gonna
get a house of event in the mcu if they
don't come in this movie i guess it's
fine there's still a good movie that can
be told here without the mutants but
look ahead at the marvel calendar for
the announced movies that they have at
least through the end of 2023 the only
title that really seems like a good
place for mutants to be introduced is
multiverse of madness now we've made
some arguments for guardians of the
galaxy vol 3. some of these other titles
you could have mutant characters who pop
up in them but they would be kind of
like tertiary characters i would say or
off world characters if you're going to
reintroduce your mutants in the mcu in a
way that it's clear to your average
moviegoer multiverse of madness seems
like the best and i would say only title
that you can do that on a large scale
yeah you can announce some random disney
plus six episode miniseries to do that
but marvel this is a big deal i think
they're gonna put that on the big screen
when they say here is our new way that
we're doing x-men i think they're gonna
do it in this movie and if it is in
multiverse of madness that would explain
why they're waiting so long because
originally multiverse of madness was
supposed to come out in may 2021
like almost a year ago at this point and
then with all the delays i think the way
they have crafted these stories they've
done it in this intricate way
so that they can't really talk about the
mutants until everyone has seen
multiverse of madness in the same way
they couldn't really talk about their
future until everyone had seen infinity
war an end game you know this is another
big event like that uh and that would be
why they haven't announced mutant
miniseries other than x-men 97 i think
they have all these plans in place
they're just waiting to be on the other
side of the movie so they can say okay
here is our sixth episode of this here's
our movie of this here's our crossover
movie including these guys so looking at
some of the rumors that we've seen
thrown around this week they're pretty
crazy do you think we'll see professor x
in this movie i i did lightly hear that
and um i think a professor x cameo is
likely because he is the face of the
x-men x-men are named after him so it
would be it would make a lot of sense
for professor x patrick stewart just to
be like hello
wanda time to stop being crazy and hello
audience remember me
he's like he's the best he's literally
the father of the fox x-men so like i
cannot imagine anyone better and you
know patrick stewart come on and you
know actually not going to say that
because that's uh morbid i was like i
was going to say he's getting out there
in age so miles will grab him while you
can but i'm not going to say that
because that's not nice um but yeah i
definitely think that patrick stewart is
the more likely damio there i mean
here's the deal like if a year ago or so
if you were to tell me patrick stewart
could come back and be like i don't know
about that the guy seems done
but the fact that they were to get able
to get toby back and andrew garfield
back and all those villains willem dafoe
alfred molina uh jamie foxx oscar winner
jamie you know the fact that they're
able to convince all these guys but just
i assume by throwing enough money at
them and giving them a good enough story
to come back
i would say patrick stewart seems more
game to show up and stuff to appease the
fans than someone like toby maguire does
tom mcguire has been kind of reclusive
in his later years but like disney they
got the strong arm they're able to get
hayden christensen back and obi-wan
compared to that getting patrick stewart
and ian mckellen to come back those guys
are game to show up anywhere you know
hard why not they're probably together
right now we can just call them right
now they're probably playing chess
somewhere on a beach living their best
lives this is why i think it's it's very
very possible at this point the way that
they've been able to craft these legacy
titles and get these legacy characters
back like yeah why not you're not gonna
i mean they've spent all this time
reshooting multiverse of madness i think
there's a reason for that this brings us
back to evan peters quicksilver if we
are flashing through the multiverse i
think this gives us a great opportunity
to
re-contextualize what evan peters cameo
in one division really was because
remember yes he was revealed as an actor
named ralph boner on his head shot in
the one division finale we were all kind
of like what he's like that was also his
identity within the hex reality the hex
was still up at that point when the hex
faded what was evan peters in this
universe then who was he in west view
before the hex went up um because we
know in the mcu there were characters
like jk simmons j jonah jameson who were
played by the same actor across them
could there already be some kind of
coincidences in this reality or could
they just do something as simple as
wanda when she's flickering through the
multiverse ends up in one reality where
evan peters is playing her brother that
would in a lot of fans minds fix
whatever that confusion was in wanda
vision and say no
that was a harbinger of things to come
that this guy showed up in your hex
reality this guy existed somewhere in
the multiverse this appearance this
actor who looks this way and you're
reaching unconsciously to a multiverse
reality to recast your brother in a
sitcom aesthetic and i think that if
they have evan peters playing her
brother even briefly like during a
montage in multiverse of madness that
would lock a lot of things in place
because evan peters quick silver was
established as the son of michael
fassbender magneto in the mcu continuity
wanda and pietro have different parents
that we met in one division episode
eight but here we would establish fast
bender to be her father as well
potentially and uh and fassbender of
course playing a younger version of ian
mckellen when they did the the x-men
first class sort of reboot but they were
all part of that same history that we
saw in days of future past so this would
allow us to have either fassbender or
ian mckellen uh in the same way that it
would allow us to have mcavoy or stuart
and we'd just be okay with both of them
and i think one cool device from uh no
way home is that it proved that when the
multiverse is involved you can pull
characters from at any point in their
lives into this reality so we did a
de-aging on willem dafoe which was super
great by the way like i can't even
believe that we've mastered de-aging
technology to this point
but we also had an older uh toby mcguire
playing the age he is in real life now
and it was fine we just are seeing these
faces again and we don't really think
too hard about it i think they had to
de-age willem dafoe and and alfred
molina because those characters died at
the at their point in their history so
they had to pull them back from you know
2002 2004 era so i think uh that could
be a simple way that we do this i think
you're gonna want a younger ian mcallen
or you're gonna want a younger magneto
you could have a version that's played
by ian mckellen and a version is played
by fassbender but i would say you might
want fastbender because i think it's
really really important to keep
magneto's origin at auschwitz uh intact
i don't want them to tell a different
version of the magnetosphere it's such a
powerful powerful origin story uh so you
can still have them from that you know
1940s 1950s 1960s origin story as a
youth and then half him the age that
fast spender is right now operating
actively in the mcu as magneto so we
could get a glimpse of ian mckellen
maybe somewhere through this flickering
multiverse montage but i think
fassbender is like the perfect choice to
play magneto now and now
so i think ultimately going forward yeah
if we're looking back at the two paths
already there or multiverse crossover i
think now the fact that they just
approved they can seamlessly do a
multiverse crossover just by getting
these actors back and by just having the
right kind of dialogue the right kind of
fan service the right kind of callbacks
yeah this could totally work and
audiences are not going to question
multiverse logic and multiverse magic
that much
especially if it is grounded somewhat in
the comics through house of m a story
that involves wanda maximoff the scarlet
witch rewriting reality in ways that
have mutants in or out of it um so what
do you think about this mt which of
these cameos do you think we're most
likely to see come back from the fox
x-men universe i think that out of you
know professor x quicksilver or magneto
the most likely of course this has got
to be quicksilver because we already
have evan peters in the mcu and they're
already setting up the you know variants
and all that so we're likely to see that
play out like you said um get some type
of satisfying ending to that in
multiverse of madness with wanda i'm
discovering uh evan peters quicksilver
but after that though i would say that
professor x is definitely the most um
again most likely because he is the face
and having magneto even though magneto
is historically wanda's father in the
comics having magneto be like i'm the
face of the x-men i'm the cameo like it
would be weird i think that professor
axe has to be the guy or at least uh
maybe even tease the coming of mutants
to the mcu because i i'm not sure if
multiverse of madness will
usher in the mcu mutants i think that we
might get the fox mutants um and all
those fun little all the fun people from
the multiverse but i think that
something still needs to happen to the
mcu proper that triggers the mutant gene
in people and i think that the guardians
three again with the high evolutionaries
is likely that route is going to trigger
something in the universe where every
planet is going to become mutantized on
a universal scale so yeah i think evan
peters then professor x then magneto
yeah i think what we might see is rather
than like one event triggers it we might
get some more context of how mutants
exist genealogically in this world i was
really hoping eternals would start that
conversation it didn't it's fine but now
it seems like yeah guardians vol 3 could
be the place where it happens it's just
i'm not really sure because james gunn
wrote that script regarding sodium iii
years ago i don't know how much feige
brought him into which of the fox
acquisitions the disney studio was
making i would imagine james gunn had
his own story he wanted to tell that had
its own priorities and then maybe they
could like
work in a through a monologue a bit like
another infinity stone uh monologue you
know the way but in this case like also
i am used to uh genealogically altering
and it works better when that species
already has a certain kind of gene we
shall call this the x gene you know i
don't know but um the x-gene or levi's
either one
i think future titles will give us um
like context for what that means
scientifically but in terms of like the
thing that introduces them rather than
it being like snap radiation or some
other kind of trigger um i think that
event will be wanda's choices in this
movie that uses the multiverse to bring
them in but i think like you know we'll
see some characters come back but i
don't think we're gonna have those all
those same actors come back i think that
would force kevin feige to commit to
casting director decisions that he had
no say over uh and in some cases he'll
want to bring them in because they're
perfect uh in some cases he may want to
recast and it might also just be because
the actor who played that doesn't want
to return i would imagine hugh jackman
is such like a game friendly guy like
i can't imagine he would balk at saying
playing wolverine through some kind of
limited cameo uh throughout this movie i
mean there was some he teased something
with some type of collaboration with
kevin feige a couple months ago or
something like that on instagram was it
so who knows how that's gonna come to
fruition but
yeah it's something about these these
musical theater dudes right like
if you're a stage actor you understand
the importance of collaboration look
this is all my head because i just
finished station 11 and it's like my
favorite show i think i've ever seen and
like it is such a triumph for theater
nerds if you watch it like it just the
whole theme of the show there's so many
deeper themes to it but one theme that i
took away from it is the power and the
magic of shakespeare and how that can
bring us together and solve all of
life's problems in some crazy right so
whenever i see uh hugh jackman during
like a curtain call for one of the shows
right now well i think they had to
suspend the productions of it but um he
did uh he's doing music man right now
and like he's so sweet during these
curtain calls and celebrating the rest
of the cast one of the understudies had
to fill in for a role last minute and he
like let her take his own take her own
curtain call um so like this is if you
watch them backstage when they were
doing production for the greatest
showman and how like much he loves the
cast like the whole ensemble
this is a guy who celebrates the
ensemble and if they could say look you
jackman here's your chance to like be
part of the celebration he's gonna be
like yeah i'll be there i'll be there
he'll be about the group
it'll be the greatest show
but i think ultimately they'll i think
hugh jackman would agree with this you
need a new wolverine in this universe
and i think he might be an example of
you know the way that like fans can have
multiple iterations of a character in
their mind the same time we can still
love andrew uh and toby and tom holland
all equally in our heads we can still
love the history of the wolverine played
by hugh jackman and then we cast some
new unknown but i think i guess the
question i have for umt the the new
person that they bring in to play
wolverine would you need this actor to
be like a young actor who you've seen in
other stuff like i'll give you the
example like lucas hedges this kid from
manchester by the sea he's really good
he's like a kid who's like of the
generation of uh chalamet and he's
probably i would say the best actor of
that generation yeah um three billboards
uh he's in lady bird he's really really
good would you need to see someone who
you kind of already are hoping gets to
be a hollywood leading man or
complete unknown the way hugh jackman
was when they cast him as wolverine in
the late 90s he was literally unknown um
for the most part um and he was so small
which is so weird see like now but i
think for me well in my opinion having a
bigger name actor only really benefits
disney and marvel studios because it
really doesn't matter to me as long as
the actor can do the job so like
big name unknown i don't care as long i
mean personally i would rather have a
short man as wolverine to match the
comics but other than that
i don't care who you get i trust sarah
haley finn with my life she could cast
my family if she would like go ahead um
so
yeah i think she i she she got this 100
i would personally would rather a lesser
known actor because the contract tends
to be smaller so like they have more of
an opportunity just to come back and
have a lengthier contract so we can keep
them longer spoken like a true studio
out of them you never know
um yeah i like i i'm going back to like
phase one and phase two when they cast
these new actors uh like we knew who
chris evans was he had played a marvel
superhero before he had been a star of a
bunch of movies with scarlett johansson
so it kind of made sense but chris
hemsworth i don't remember seeing in a
ton of stuff before he was announced as
thor oh i remember reading an article a
couple weeks ago like about tom
hiddleston and chris comes with this up
when they were first cast as thor in
thor and they were like oh two unknowns
like marvel risks at all with two
unknowns i'm like really risk it all
it's so weird looking back at it now
like these are two staples of the mcu
and then now we've seen it in later
years um similar playing chiang chi
when they initially cast chadwick
boseman as as black panther like all
these choices paid off for them you know
uh and we we just immediately trust
these these great performers to do these
roles so uh yeah i i think um whatever
direction they want to do if they want
to go for an unknown i i think fans
would accept that as long as the
person's game for the role and and ready
to commit to it because it is a huge
physical commitment to play these roles
i can definitely marvel like in a secret
wars scenario having um hugh jackman
wolverine team up with whatever next
wolverine that they're bringing just so
like they can help the audience accept
this new wolverine because i feel like
wolverine is gonna be a really hard role
to recast so if you have them team up
and then have that new wolverine branch
off from there i think that's a good way
to sort of just hand hold your audience
and be like it's okay it's okay like
old wolverine approved so it's fine
that i could imagine happening like we
we introduced the idea of mutants coming
in from the multiverse through
quicksilver through professor x through
magneto but they punt on wolverine and
some of the more popular x-men names
that we know into other titles like
secret wars but it gives us something to
look forward to i mean we already have a
ton to look forward to his secret wars
they love dangling the carrot man i
don't need all my mutant questions
answered in multiverse of madness just
like give us some kind of direction of
who's gonna show us a little ankle kevin
we need some ankles
[Laughter]
now uh we are going to talk a lot more
about this movie but first the staff at
new rock stars can sometimes be night
owl staying up late to finish a video or
watch one of these midnight episode
drops on disney plus but when we go to
sleep we want it to be on a great
mattress a helix mattress helix sleep is
a sleep quiz that matches your body type
and your sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you they have soft
medium and fur mattresses mattress is
great for cooling you down if you sleep
hot even a helix plus mattress for plus
size sleepers i have a helix mattress i
love it the quit the quiz matched me to
a medium firm mattress with lumbar
support that sleeps cool the mattress
ships right to your door for free no
need to go to a mattress store just go
to helixsleep.com
inside marvel take their two minute
sleep quiz they'll match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life they have a
10 year warranty and you get to try it
out for 100 nights risk-free they'll
even pick it up for you if you don't
love it but you will helix is offering
up to 200 off all mattress orders and
two free pillows for our listeners at
helixleap.com inside marvel we also want
to thank bluetooth for sponsoring this
episode we're pretty confident in our
theories here on inside marvel and
confidence can take you pretty far in
life and in the bedroom and that's where
blue chew comes in blue chew is a unique
online service that delivers the same
active ingredients as viagra and cialis
but in chewable tablets and at a
fraction of the cost you can plan ahead
or be ready for whenever an opportunity
arises the process is simple sign up at
bluetooth.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days and it's all
done online so no business to the
doctor's office no awkward conversations
no waiting in line at the pharmacy
bluetooth tablets are made in the usa
and prepared and shipped direct to your
door in a discrete package so if you
could benefit from some extra confidence
when it's time to perform bluetooth can
help and we've got a special deal for
our listeners try bluetooth free when
you use our promo code marvel at
checkout just pay the five dollars in
shipping that's bluetooth.com promo code
marvel to receive your first month free
visit bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information and we
thank bluetooth for sponsoring this show
all right mta i want to ask you the
event of multiverse of madness based off
of what we know from the trailer from
other things how tied how connected do
you think multiverse madness will be to
one division oh super connected i think
that one division is going to be
like the cornerstone of what is
happening in multiverse of madness we've
seen from the trailers that chaos energy
seems to be the name of the game and it
seems like from from what i'm guessing
defender strange is closed we see the
fender strange and the action figures
and stuff wearing all red and that gives
me the vibe of like maybe this is evil
doctor strange who has messed around
with a lot of chaos magic and is wearing
a lot of red darkness like wanda does
like this is the chaos it's sort of like
a scarlet wizard in a way so i think
that the dark hole in particular the
dark hold and chaos magic front stage
and center in um wanda vision are going
to be extremely important in multiverse
madness as the dark hold is probably
what drives evil doctor strange to
make things go out of hand so yeah i
think that um this multiverse of madness
will get a lot of people who haven't
seen one division should just go back
and be like all right now i'm curious as
to how all of this went down i i think
you're right mt i think those of us who
were glued to wandavision pouring
through every detail are going to get a
lot out of this movie and it's going to
be the big screen payoff to a lot of our
burning questions a lot of our theories
that we had during wanda vision for
people who might not have checked out
wandavision i don't know who you are
first of all because one division was a
title that brought a lot of non fans to
the fold of marvel but um i assume there
are many of you out there i think they
will find watching one division to be
just a delightful
experience in all kinds of ways whether
you just love classic television i don't
know if it's going to be required
viewing though i think
other than the references because i
think for like the people go see
infinity war on the third weekend right
like do they need to have seen every
marvel title to get what's going on in
that movie no they should because
they'll they'll better appreciate movies
like infinity war and in-game in the
same way that you'll better appreciate
no way home if you've seen every
spider-man live-action movie that came
out beforehand but you could just walk
into spider-man no way home maybe having
seen the first tobey mcguire movie maybe
having read an article saying that they
were recasting it as andrew garfield and
they later recast it as tom holland and
you'll still
pretty much like that movie because they
designed them in ways to be super
accessible um but they have these little
lines in here that are thrown in for
fans who know the references so i think
ultimately multiverse of madness is
going to give us enough context by
things like i'm not here to talk about
westview but the fact that wanda and
strange are fighting over the dark hold
i think it's going to be crucial and
critical going back after you've seen
multiples of madness to watch one
division is going to be an even more
delightful experience oh absolutely
because you're just going to see how
wanda got to this point she can already
bridge through the threshold of media to
pull into other franchises i just don't
know how meta they're gonna get with it
like if you know the fox x-men
continuity is something that existed in
another
like franchise like a whole other
timeline of the multiverse or will be
something that like kind of existed
through a televised medium that was
already within the mcu because if you do
these tommy westfall connections you can
already start to connect like well this
actor was in a movie with this actor
well the brady bunch exists in a reality
where this character this actor went on
to work with that other actor brian
cranston was in on the tv in that
episode of juan division so does that
mean brian cranston can't play a villain
now in the mcu
probably not probably not i think we're
overthinking it at that point
i would love to see brian grant's in the
mcu that'd be dope
yeah he's incredible how tight do you
think multiverse of madness will be to
infinity war end game because in this
trailer that we just watched there was
that little line where like he says it
was the only way reminding us of him uh
looking ahead at the 14 million
different futures and making this
decision do you think this movie will be
a direct consequence of strange's
choices or will it be something that
like you and i when we watch it we kind
of infer that oh because he did these
things differently or is he going to
mention thanos i guess that's my
question how much is thanos going to be
part of this story i think that yeah
infinity war and game are going to be
the main events that sort of trigger all
of these holes opening in reality and
because like when you mess with gravity
in the mcu
weird wormholes start to open up we saw
it in doctor strange one in a small way
when doctor strange messes with the book
and when he's messing with the time
stone and mortar was like yo if you mess
with the time stone you are going to
cause time loops um spatial disruptions
temporal anomalies yeah temporal
anomalies all that stuff so we're seeing
what warnow said in action so what
doctor strange did in infinity war he
used the time stone to look at all those
realities which he probably shouldn't
have done and then thanos used the time
stone to
you know take everybody out and hulk
used it to bring everybody back so
that's a really a lot of misuses of this
really crucial part of reality so of
course the glitches in the matrix are
coming up and all these holes are
opening up so infinity war and game are
the start launching points to everything
there is happening in this movie so yeah
there's gonna be a lot of differences i
i just find it interesting how much
phase four already seems to still be
reminding us of the consequences of the
infinity stone saga you know uh and i
don't think they're fully done with what
happened there all these things are kind
of interconnected in the same way that
like you know in civil war we were
dealing with the consequences of age of
ultron in in the first avengers film
they love to make this all part of like
a shared history with lots of historical
consequences they mentioned the snap and
thanos in eternals but i i'm wondering
do you think multiverse of madness will
use the term absolute point to define
the snap do we think the snap in the
context of this reality was an absolute
point that strange found a very clever
way of bypassing i think that if they
are if they introduce that concept in
that what if episode four at the doctor
strange episode then we're definitely
most likely going to hear it again in
multiverse of madness because that same
episode introduced the concept of an
evil doctor strange i mean they did say
the producers of what if did say that
like absolute point was their lexicon
that they came up with for that show and
had they known of what was going to
happen in loki they probably would have
used a term like nexus
or something like that but nexus point
is kind of the opposite of an absolute
point a nexus point is where things
branch off and they do but an absolute
point is something where nothing can be
branched off of it or past it you can't
go around it it all the branches lead to
this absolute point no matter what you
do christine palmer's death was an
absolute point in that episode but in
the mcu that was not the case at least
back in 2016 but do you think that
christine palmer's death will be treated
as an absolute point in multiverse of
madness we see her in her wedding day
but do we think that will lead to some
kind of tragic event where she dies
constantly constantly and that is just
something that strange has to deal with
also in this movie i hope not because
that sort of gets into fridging
territory and like i feel like christine
palmer in the first movie she was great
but like i really wanted more from that
character rather than being just like
i'm just supporting you like emotionally
so like for her just to be used as a
device i'm like alright i'm just gonna
kill you over and over again i wouldn't
be a huge fan i'd be fine with it i'm
not gonna be like oh no this is the
worst but i would rather christine
palmer be more than that however dr
strange is very vulnerable when it comes
to matters of christine palmer so for
her to you know die is something that he
as we saw in epis in what if episode
four he just can't handle that so it
would make sense for the absolute voice
to be introduced in that way much like
it was and what if for sure see i need
to do more um reading on what exactly
the i'm familiar with the concept of
fridging and i have the same kind of
like reaction to when movies do that as
well um
that's where they just essentially bring
a woman into a story and then put her in
a fridge a metaphorical fridge and just
she's just there to die to motivate the
hero and she's given no real
characterization other than that but i
honestly don't have a problem with
through this multiverse logic of a film
in that in that what if episode if you
do kill off the character of christine
palmer if if through the logic of the
movie through the multiverse we're able
to extract her from that scenario and
still give the character agency and a
proper storyline and character
development um but if you say that she
was destined to die i don't think
there's nothing wrong with having a
character who was just destined to die
and seeing a character try tragically to
avoid that so long as you structurally
in the film you st you still give that
character a history in a future um so
that they can like grow and change and
do other things you know in the story
but i also wonder if like someone more
educated than me and fridgy might say
well you're still creating a scenario
where we're first forced to watch a
woman violently die over and over again
and what does that do to our brains if
we just kind of reinforce this repeated
violence over and over again that's kind
of effed up in another way um i don't
need to see another montage of christine
palmer dying but uh it was i really
liked that episode of what if
they have a problem with the way it was
shown there but um but yeah i think we
do get to see christine palmer it looks
like joined doctor strange on a
multiversal trip alongside america
chavez so i i think she's gonna be doing
a lot more in this movie do your thing
about absolute point to nexus points i
think that what marvel studios might end
up doing is what they just sort of do
with like the wizards and the science
people in the mcu it's like the wizards
have their own terms and the science
people have their own terms so like the
tva is more sciency so nexus point might
be the same thing that absolute point is
that the wizards just call it so it's
just like it's the same
name just like the wizards call energy
magic it's the same difference yeah it's
just like different
words i guess but i would prefer if like
they can just start to line all that up
and make it clear you know like
if when you say something is an absolute
point or an infinity stone should be an
infinity stone uh across like we should
all have some kind of sense of order i
understand that's really hard to do that
is asking a lot from kevin feige when
they're trying to preserve story
integrity they're trying to give
director independence uh they're trying
to make all these stories unique in
their own way uh they don't want to
spoil things that are happening in the
future so far they've done a pretty damn
good job um but when i hear things like
a show runner on one show saying oh well
they just you know we weren't able to
see all the notes of what they're doing
on loki we would have called it nexus
points otherwise then i'm kind of like
you really can't that's an episode one
of loki just to define what um a nexus
branch is or a nexus event is i don't
think it would have ruined anything it
would have helped what if it might have
been like the loki writers didn't come
with that yet yet but i think the loki
writers were already writing that show i
think this was just a point where they
didn't see everything that they were
doing decisions weren't made yet
whatever i'm i'm complaining about
something that isn't that big of a deal
i don't care i don't think you're
complaining we're just obsessed like
we're just analyzing man it's not
complaining at all yeah i'm just
analyzing i honestly am okay if a nexus
event is different than an absolute
point in the mcu i prefer if an absolute
point is something completely different
than the next no not me i'm going to go
into a deep rage eric
well that is it for this episode of
inside marvel
we're going gonna be back every week
talking whatever the biggest marvel
question is for us at this at the start
of every week uh when moon night comes
back this this show will turn back into
a moon night after show um but for now
i'm just kind of enjoying like tackling
some of these bigger questions with you
every week empty and save it love you
buddy this is great love marvel well
don't forget to check out our many great
merch options at newrockstarsmerch.com
you can follow me at eavos on social
media you can follow mt at
mastertainment subscribe to inside
marvel wherever you get your podcasts
thank you for watching bye
you